it's about minus 20 right now you add in
the wind chill you can easily be around
minus 60 so it's gonna be real chilly
day we're gonna be heading out with the
hailstones obviously there's two
obstacles in a situation like this hey
you have to keep up with the chip and
Agnes and B you still have a show to
shoot so you know you got to make sure
you're getting the right coverage we
have a person in the back to sled like
this it's really cool because one of our
other guys will be driving essentially
and the guy back here will be able to
get tracking shots and traveling shots
side by side as the health stones go up
to Coba River here do I always get as
many angles as we can on the show just
gives the editors back home a little bit
more to work with and for this trip the
health stones are going to be doubling
up similar to me and this will be
beautiful acne on our knees for me and
I'll be chip and
yeah it should be pretty pretty good
there
wave to the camera Agnes all right sweet
quite a few respond we're trying to do
these kind of shots I mean I'm slitting
and sitting in a basket sled I'm wearing
a helmet with goggles which makes it
very hard to see my camera and see what
I'm shooting there's an opportunity for
the hitch to break on the trailer and I
could slide off the thing could flip
over there's all kinds inherent risk out
there there's only a few places in the
world where you can travel up the river
get to another town all my snow machine
and bastard slits really cool not to
mention make some awesome TV weather is
just so unpredictable I hear it's always
keeping us on my toes
checking in from Prudhoe Bay Alaska here
at Deadhorse we tried to ship the crew
in the pier out last night ended up
running out of daylight so I got stuck
here overnight with the gear and we have
a bit of a blizzard blowing now so
little nerve-racking we have a lot of
the gear here camera lenses and
batteries and chargers that need to get
out there to the guys just a waiting
game right now
Wayne is our di TAC slash everything man
and he's not here with all the equipment
unfortunately so what we have been doing
was conserving these little guys these
are the batteries for the c300 we have
seven of them and we have zero chargers
so what we're going to do is utilize
these little guys and shoot lots and
lots of specialty
we're trying to make the best of it it's
like below zero